some people may think how can it be that
somebody can be both gay and a cowboy
because the cowboy is the model of the
macho masculine man that it doesn't
matter whether you're a man or a woman
whether you're a butch or nelly
everybody can find a place within our
community within our rodeo circuit
that's who we are
[Music]
my name is bruce grow and i'm the
president of the international gay rodeo
association
we're celebrating our 30th anniversary
of our finals rodeo today
cowboys and cowgirls compete in 13
events so that the best of the best are
represented in our sport at this event
today
my name is greg begaye i'm an all-around
cowboy and i'm gay i grew up on the
navajo reservation being on the
reservation you kind of find things to
do and rodeo was one of them
gay rhodia is more than just a
celebration i think it's a place for
people to be comfortable i don't have to
worry about hiding anything
years ago professional cowboys looked
upon us as mocking their sport as
they've come to know us more they come
to appreciate and understand the fact
that we embrace the same sport they do
we may express it a little bit
differently but we still have the same
passion and dedication to being good
competitors good cowboys and cowgirls
that they do
gay rodeo offers
a few different events that traditional
rodeo doesn't we offer wild drag race
and
go dressing
in our rodeo men and women can compete
in every event equally you're going to
see men in drat
i don't know that when people really
come to know us they're going to find a
more warm supportive friendly experience
than they'll find here with us gay rodeo
is a safe space for people to be
accepted with each other i've
established a rodeo family here i can
always count on people
and they can count on me
[Music]
you